This is the Mann family from Cornwall - and
these are their provisions.
Food and drink for several months for five
people plus their cat and dog - just in case:
there's the worst case.We're not stocking
up for war, but for Brexit.
The Manns have always been against Britain
leaving the EU.
And everything they've heard from London in
the last two years makes them think Brexit
is going to be a chaotic process.
They've bought a water tank with filter and
because the UK gets some of its electricity
from Europe, they're getting ready
for power cuts.
The whole family helps out with the weeding.
They hope that their home-grown greens will
soon be ready to eat.
Is all this a bit too much?
Maybe.
But midwife Nevine says they are simply going
on what they've heard from their government.
Die Regierung hat jetzt gesagt, es könnten
sechs Monate werden in denen nur 15 - 20 % der
Importe ins Land kommen.
Bislang haben wir gedacht, dass wir Lebensmittel
für drei Monate brauchen werden.
Deshalb kaufen wir jetzt noch mehr ein.
Wir hatten das Problem unterschätzt.
The Mann family say they only rely on themselves.
Others haven't yet given up the fight yet.
It's early morning in London and a group of
young people are about to get on a campaign
bus.
Their organisation is called 'Our future,
our choice'.
Just like 59 percent of the British population,
they want a second referendum.
Es gibt so viel zu tun.
In ein paar Jahren werden wir zurückblicken
und uns fragen, ob wir damals genug getan
haben.
Der Wind hat sich gedreht.
Jetzt haben wir wirklich eine Chance.
According to polls, some 77 percent of Britons
under the age of 24 would vote against leaving
the EU.
And every day, more young people are becoming
old enough to vote.
The message that these ativists are promoting
- 'Please Stand Up for Our Future.
'
The Mann family in Cornwall have long since
given up hoping Britain will remain in the
EU.
They don't think it going to end well either
- so they're heading back to the shops to
stock up on more food.